talk about the dark side of social media
oh gosh I'm sure there's a really really
dark side that I don't know about to me
the ultimate dark side would be getting
caught up in it you know like i said
spending too much time designing your
background on Twitter or Facebook or
whatever I'd say that's part of the dark
side is just getting caught up in at
timewise perhaps I think it's very easy
to mistake commenting or it's very easy
to mistake being involved in the
filmmaking community in the filmmaking
discussion with being a filmmaker so
because you go to things because you
talk about things because you know
certain people you feel like you're a
filmmaker you're in the community but
you're not making films just because
you're commenting on articles or films
or whatever this is not making a
filmmaker so that's probably a major
danger of social media and any other
kind of filmmaking community type
activity or event and i would say
another major danger is it just it could
fuel your own sense of delusion man you
know you know perhaps you're just a
really good twitter or whatever you're
called you know you tweet really well or
you're really good at creating a
perception of success and talent but in
the long run its its foundation list
there's there's nothing you don't have a
body of work to back it up with so you
might be really witty you know commenter
or poster on facebook or whatever but in
the end if you don't have the material
to back it up with what's the point you
know so so that's a great example maybe
you're meant to do something else you
know maybe you're meant to be a writer
maybe you're meant to be like like a
publicist or an agent or whatever you
know maybe you're you should start a
film festival or something let go the
the the delusion and embrace what you're
good at so I would say like that's the
dangers that I've
seen with social media what if you let
go of the filmmaker title but you
through being around that artistic
energy then it rubs off on you and then
you feel the confidence or the
inspiration the ideas whatever to go out
make that film is that okay or yeah I
mean absolutely that's a positive thing
yeah I mean if you I think there's place
for everyone to get involved repost like
or our blogs like film courage listen to
your podcasts and and you know of course
like Ted hopes blog I mean it could be
very encouraging as inspiring and
helpful information I hope people watch
this you know but if it's if it's
becoming a hindrance to making films
then that's what it's counterproductive
and pointless you know and I just
thought of another dark side which is
again this is the kind of stuff that
people tend not to talk about but
there's there's a there's a major major
temptation with social media and end to
seek to find encouragement through it so
Christopher J bogosian likes Christopher
J bogosian and invites you to like
Christopher J because you too I'm sure
you've gotten those emails people
creating their own Facebook page and
inviting you to like their own page or
posting their video on Facebook and
hoping for comments and likes and all
this stuff so my point is that there's a
emotional psychological danger which is
going turning to social media for a
sense for your self esteem for
encouragement for a sense of self-worth
affirmation when in reality you're
probably not going to get it so that's a
danger you got to be really careful an
honest with yourself why am i posting my
video why am I commenting why am i doing
all these things in my ultimately
because i'm seeking encouragement if you
are it's probably a bad idea what do you
think about social media addiction in
five years addiction well it probably
exists right now yeah I've seen I
haven't really read but I've definitely
seen titles of people proposing that it
exists you know professors and
psychology so yeah but that's like way
beyond anything I've thought over her to
read
you